your electric is very enthusiastic about
the energy union it's probably the
crucial parts which has been lacking
until now we think that we have a lot of
good proposes seen from the EU the fact
that the EU is sitting around the table
now with the ministers of all the Member
States will built and foundation which
is essential to have a cooperation in
Europe big the European consumer
organization welcomes the energy union
package and the strategy because this
strategy says that consumers are at the
centre of the energy union
so the energy union for us is really a
grand marshal plan steering us in terms
of investment and new business
innovation it also demonstrates and
vice-president SEF kovitch has been
fantastic is making the link between the
2030 package on climate and energy and
the energy union that actually the
European Union is now fundamentally
looking at how we can move towards
decarbonisation
so putting the citizen and consumer
first and addressing his needs with a
maximum of local and energy-efficient
solutions that is for us the real change
in the concept of the energy unit and
will be also the biggest challenge for
the realization of the energy unit
siddik and the local energy companies
strongly support vice-president selvage
to transform this vision into reality
we support the drive by the European
Commission to create a functioning
energy union once it recognizes and
empowers the building sector as a key
priority sector for ambitious action in
the achievement of the five dimensions
of the framework we hope and trust that
the intentions of the European
Commission as announced in the EU energy
union will translate into ambitious
well-designed policy proposals in 2016
project of energy union at the very
successful one energy union is one of
the very important instrument to do so
and after his successful start a union
we believe that EU will be even more
active in addressing the challenges of
the global energy governance
the era TP group is a strong supporter
of the energy and climate strategy of
the European Commission we are one of
your ambassadors of the entire public
transport sector @interface were very
supportive of a truly open European
energy market where the best innovations
expand across the continent that is why
we are firm backers of the energy union
project an energy union would help
businesses pull their efforts to
collectively come up with even better
technologies the one called the European
energy union promoting secure and
climate plan with friendly energy is of
significant importance for the region of
Vasa where we have the largest energy
cluster in the Nordic countries and are
working in a global environment
so for me the energy union is really
about how Europe can prosper and thrive
in this new energy world they're using
the power of concerted action across
borders it's early days still the PNG
Union is in its first year but it's
absolutely critical that we make it work
to secure our prosperity and our
security now the concept of energy union
for the first time is looking at the
whole energy system and equally at the
supply side and the demand side and we
welcome this development
I cannot enough appreciate the dialogue
stakeholder engagement that we've seen
throughout the energy union tour
attended personally by vice-president
chef George and his team we will
therefore be happy to work with the
Commission and the Slovak government to
make the union a reality and to make
Europe more efficient and successful in
the future I wish to congratulate the
European Commission for the latest steps
on the energy union which we find is a
very important and timely instant for
you what we believe is the most
important is looking how we can work
with energy efficiency in buildings and
not deep at least link it to the quality
of the buildings and the value of the
property looking at the indoor plants
that man is a strong supporter of the
NAD Union we need the Renewable Europe
with more in stronger grades to secure
energy supplies for us interconnectors
are key to the success of the energy and
that the impetus of the energy union we
can make Europe enjoy affordable energy
sources well-developed infrastructure
and the free flow of resources and we
strongly support the vision of the
energy union which is making Europe
whole free and secure the period from
2020 to 2030 is likely to become the
breakthrough century where renewable
energy technologies such as offshore
wind and biomass becomes fully
competitive with fossil fuels driven by
decreasing cost and a meaningful price
for co2 the energy union is an important
step in this direction as it supports
Europe's continued leadership within the
energy transformation